you knew him didn't you then you had
that one little feeling
but you waved it away
you should have listened to that one
little feeling
just like i'm listening to you now you
can talk to me
i'm all a friend
you're not exactly a department favorite
thing's probably changed a lot since he
left
you still got to catch him right yeah
not that much has changed then
i can assure you all we are taking a 24
7 all hands on deck approach to these
cases
guy's a shock if he stops he dies he
likes to drive probably has a decent car
maybe too
high mileage you must really like my car
i do how's the trunk space
some of my got to know how's the guy
with the best clearance rate in the
department worked 15 years without a
promotion
maybe i didn't go to the right church
when i look in your eyes what i see
it ain't good
[Music]
he knew all the details but he wasn't
within 10 miles of the killing
why hate
[Music]
how's the trunk space
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you want i want to nail the
bastard for
all of the girls he killed
[Music]
i want to know difference is
i'm doing this for me
[Music]
it's little things jimmy it's the little
things that rip you apart it's the
little things that
get you caught
[Music]
you